ces derniers mois de nouveaux articles
font état de divers débordements et
affrontements impliquant des violences
contre des représentants de l'état ya
jérémy vrai au maire de la ville de bron
près de lyon qui était victime d'une
attaque sur son véhicule de fonction
alors qu'il était en visite dans un
quartier sensible de la ville il y avait
un groupe d'une dizaine d'individus qui
était là lorsque nous sommes arrivés sur
facebook le maire a décidé de publier
les photos de sa voiture totalement
détruite pour faire prendre conscience
de la violence particulièrement forte à
destination des élus grave encore le
maire et ses équipes ont été directement
agressés par les jeunes visiblement là
pour en découdre
nous avons été la cible d'insultés de
menaces physiques et de jets de
projectiles
j'irai me briot a décidé de porter
plainte alors rixe vandalisme doit-on
avoir peur de notre jeunesse
[Musique]
jérémy bréau le maire de bron et son
équipe ont été agressés dont c'était
donc hier après midi dans un quartier de
leur commune l'élu l'est républicain
diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux une
photo de la voiture municipale dans
laquelle il se déplacer alors notre
question rixe vandalisme doit-on avoir
peur de notre jeunesse c'est vrai que
c'est la grosse grosse caisse
aujourd'hui merci yacine d'être là il ya
six nouvelles assez merci jean messia
alors oui non on va démarrer par on va
démarrer par allez on va démarrer par
vous si beato vous voulez qu'on l'est et
marie-jo ambitionnons chance jean messia
alyzia vous pensez qu'on doit avoir peur
de notre jeunesse
bref quelle jeunesse quoiqu'elle
jeunesse bas toute la jeunesse c'est la
jeunesse c'est pas un bleu comme ça oui
certaine jeunesse effectivement il faut
en avoir peur oui alors vous vous parlez
de quoi ben yahia des jeunes
effectivement qui qui sont ce que jean
pierre chevènement il ya plusieurs
années appelé les jeunes sauvageons
il ya une jeunesse qui habite
effectivement d un certain nombre de
quartiers qui sont plus d'ailleurs des
quartiers on est en france et y habitent
pas par pas ça mais j'ai changé j'ai
habité dans cette affaire est bel et
bien sûr un réajustement mais
m'attendais mais moi je les stigmatise
pas je considère que ces jeunes là sont
des victimes et sont victimes de deux
choses il son fils tim effectivement
d'une politique migratoire folle qui
fait arriver en france chaque année
d
des centaines de milliers de personnes
alors que la france n'a plus la capacité
de les accueillir et d'une économie qui
est à l'arrêt avant on s'intégrer par le
travail vous et le chômage des jeunes
aujourd'hui qui est qui et qui atteint
25 % de la population des airs de 25 %
des jeunes sont au chômage par exemple
beaucoup de jeunes sont au rsa il
bénéficie des ce défilé de solidarité
etc
donc il ya une exclusion qui fait que
les jeunes n'entre pas dans la vie
active n'entre pas sur le marché du
travail
et malgré ça eh bien on continue
l'afflux migratoire qui qui voilà qui ça
provoque des goulets d'étranglement
s'ils voulaient donc toute la jeunesse
n'est pas à brocarder moi j'ai des
jeunes chez moi ils font peur à personne
ils me font pas peur à moi
voilà donc pour badernes tous les jeunes
il y a effectivement des jeunes qui
posent problèmes qui sont dans une dans
une dérive d'abord sociales qui sont
également dans une dérive scolaire parce
qu'il ya des échecs scolaires qui fait
que ben voilà on sort de l'école on fait
des conneries
il ya aussi une dérive je dirais
judiciaire parce que effectivement quand
on fait sa première connerie et que
derrière vous avez pas les flics qui fin
quand les flics vous arrête la justice
ni bon il est mineur et leur trouve des
excuses etc
ils sont libérés du coup la fois d'après
on se dit baba sciolla on n'a rien si on
n'a rien risqué si on a on n'a rien pris
ça va continuer voilà et donc vous avez
comme ça un processus qui relève à la
fois de l'économie qui relève du social
qui relève du ppt et du judiciaire et du
pénal qui relève du migratoires qui fait
qu'il y à une racaille isation de la
jeunesse française
voilà alors bien aidé à sync est ce que
tout de suite à son bien non moi
j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis de alors
oui et des non classés
alors bien évidemment moi je suis pas du
tout sûr ce débat je suis sur un autre
débat qui est qu'il ya eu un grand
chantier en 2005 de politique de la
ville où déjà on parlait de la jeunesse
désoeuvrée
en fait il n'y a pas d'avenir pour une
certaine jeunesse
c'est une génération qui a été touché de
plein fouet par ce chômage violents des
parents et qui se retrouve aujourd'hui
sans aucun avenir alors moi je parle pas
des banlieues je parle en général c'est
à dire qu'être jeune aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement difficile
il n'y a pas de projet social il n'y a
pas d'avenir y a rien de concret on est
rejeté de l'école assez facilement des
moments on est un peu marginaux
lisez donc là où je me pose des
questions c'est ça fait des années et
des années qu'on parle de grands projets
justement pour nos jeunes aujourd'hui a
toujours pas de projet ils vers des jeux
dit non il faut surtout pas exclure pas
criminaliser faut pas rejeter
il faut intégrer aider cette jeunesse là
monsieur elle n'a rien elle n'a pas
d'avenir pas d'espoir pas de travail on
envoie 100 policiers dans l'essonne
d'accord mais ce qu'il faut c'est des
éducateurs ces deux-là programme énoncé
après vous dites la politique migratoire
mais les migrants n'ont rien à voir avec
ça c'est pas les maires ruraux
m'attendais la politique migratoire ça
c'est l'immigration monsieur c'est pas
les migrants à quelques l'immigration à
l'épaule depuis 40 ans donc
effectivement il ya un stock d'individus
qui ne s'intègrent pas notre société qui
n'a pas envie de s'intégrer tu est une
réalité
voilà pour quelques actes isolés
condamnable condamnable et pas isolé
match et vous stigmatisez tout est pas
isolé depuis vous avez tous les gérards
d'immigration comme parent avait tous
les jours des dizaines d'agressions mais
non agression verbale attendait alors
vous voyez que des faits divers des
multiplication de faits divers mais mais
vous sortez allez demander aux français
bon sens la violence en france et il
n'explose ion de la violence des jeunes
si vous reconnaissez pas ça vous vivez
dans vos vies mais pas en france en cas
si alarmant évidemment je pense que déjà
jean missira se trompe en faisant un
lien entre l'immigration et les
violences urbaines mais en dix ans mais
si tu le fais le lien
d'accord mais moi je suis assez fier tu
sois là parce que tu émane d'un fléau
qui s'appelle l'immigration que ce que
tu aimes année en france vous émettez
après pour aller acheter les émigrations
j'ai passé les migrations iliad et si tu
veut classer les immigrés ça m'a bien
sûr on va toute personne évidemment il
ya des bonnes immigration jeter écouté
et je pense ce qui vient de se passer
est condamnable en tout point n'y a pas
un un fait divers atroce moi je pense
aussi qu'il ya le fait que nous sommes
dans une société de faits divers
on a tous vécu à travers les médias
depuis des années et ce qui était un
autre filet de quatre lignes avants page
4 et dorénavant un fait majeur c'est à
dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il se passe
quelque chose parce que évidemment des
partis que tu soutiens ont décidé de
faire croire c'est leur faute alors mais
laisse moi aller au bout c'est
incroyable je sais qu'ils n'arrêtent pas
ce que tu dois t'adapter à notre pays
mais laisse moi ou ma phrase mais juste
pour préciser quelque chose à partir du
moment où aujourd'hui tu pars du
principe que nous et gilles verdez
pardon d'aller danser
don de parler dans votre sens on parle
plus d'intégration pour les gens comme
moi c'est qu'intégration ça voudrait
dire que je suis encore extérieur moi je
suis pas intégrer je suis français donc
depuis le début de mon histoire je le
suis que tu parle d'éducation moi ça me
dérange pas parce que je vais te dire il
ya toujours eu un problème de la
jeunesse
d'ailleurs tu es quelqu'un d'érudit
cellier un texte de socrate qui dit que
chaque jeunesse qui vient est pire que
la précédente mais c'est dorénavant
amplifiée par un phénomène qui
n'existait pas avant
parce que pardon te dire ça et monsieur
pernikoff c'est que avant les quartiers
étaient vraiment ostracisé par rapport
au reste de la ville et il ya eu l'anru
depuis 2005 et le plan borloo qui a fait
que déjà on a ouvert sur des sites et
physiquement avant les cités c'est un
corps à part mais surtout le phénomène
des portables il ya quelques mois vous
avez reçu ici le petit youri des cas de
rixe comme ça entre bandes ça a toujours
existé
la preuve ça vient même pas des arabes
et des noirs etc déjà renault qui se
vantait d'avoir uni ben ouais mais ça
mérite juste pour aller au bout
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que avec la
violence des portables moi même qui ai
39 ans aujourd'hui quand je vois des
jeunes aller tabasser un mec et au
passage le film et pour le mettre sur
les réseaux ça raconte des sociétés
ultraviolents qualité pardon te dire ça
je te dise à un an d'une élection va pas
pouvoir faire une campagne là dessus
parce que les parents eux mêmes qui sont
des gens de ma génération sont dépassés
par la violence de leurs enfants
et pardon te dire ça moi même j'ai fait
le coup à mes parents c'est que mes
parents découvrez quel enfant j'étais
aussi en allant au collège
et c'est parce que j'avais un père qui a
été un peu physique qui m'a éduqué mais
il ya aussi la faute la responsabilité
des parents qui ont aussi à beaucoup de
mamans célibataires c'est un fléau qui
touche le pays des petites nanas qui ont
des gamins qui ont 15 16 ans comment
veux-tu qu'une nana qui grandit avec
trois quatre enfants même 2 avec un
enfant qui est aux hormones qui est
balèze et qui va essayer d'avoir un
ascendant physique sur la liste et tu me
le seul et tu peux pas condamner excuses
là c'était au nom mais j'attends je
comprends parfaitement ce que tu dis
sauf que moi déjà de mon temps je suis
plus très jeune déjà de montanges avait
des tas de copains et de copines dont
les parents étaient séparés divorcés à
des seules leurs enfants
et c'était pas pour ça qu'ils allaient
planter un camarade ou lui mettre un
coup de poing ou là nous tabasser à
coups de barre de fer
moi je veux bien on tombe toutes les
excuses mais au bout d'un moment là la
violence d'abord elle explose c'est pas
le fait divers dont tu parles de qui
amplifiaient simplement par les médias
ce n'est pas un effet de loupe c'est que
objectivement les faits divers sont de
plus
ou tu veux faire pourrait l'être un truc
tu trouves que là je n'avais pas
d'autres chats à fouetter à une
manifestation samedi deux générations et
des faits divers ça la pression excuse
moi de te poser cette question que la
jeunesse que tu avais chez génération
identitaire faire le salut nazi n'a plus
tard maxime brunerie si tu veux c'est
pas ça le débat trouve ça long en place
par 12 ça n'était pas arrivé
excusez moi de vous dire ça depuis des
années mais est ce que je te pose une
question simple tu comprend le français
a priori tant pis je te dis ce que tu
penses que la jeunesse qui était chez
génération identitaire vaut mieux que la
soi-disant racaille isation parce que
rak alisation je vais donner alors et
partager des moments mais répondent à
cette raison majeure et je vais poser
les questions combien de jeunes de
génération identitaires ont poignardé à
mort des gens mais à tous cas pas c'est
déborah domaine et labrador ils ont été
koala excuse mais puis génération vous
tu ne vas pas sur ce débat là les jeunes
de génération identitaire ils défendent
leur pain pays qui s'appelle la france
que toi puisque tu me connais peut-être
que tu me dis que tu es pas un têtu me
dis que tu as intégré que tu es français
alors d'ailleurs j'aimerais te poser une
question donc en fait tu es raciste
puisque tu dis que les français sont
racistes mais c'est bien pour ça a été
rapide mais toi ça papa voilà je sais
que la voirie minutes même si c'est nous
avec un débat qui dit les arabes pour
quoi ils servent à rien ne me colle pas
des mots parce que je n'ai jamais dit
non des gens je veux dire et je contiens
une fatwa jma khechna d'un contrôle
raciste question ce que les jeunesses se
valent
aux yeux de jean messia j'ai dit que tu
es capable de la junte qu'aujourd'hui la
jeunesse française dans son intégralité
poussé par des réseaux sociaux liés
aussi à une société ultra violents qui
s'appelle excuse moi je vous la société
américaine qui aujourd'hui lutte contre
un autre fléau liée à sa jeunesse c'est
des gamins qui rentre avec un fusil et
qui tua 29 copa dans une classe j'ai pas
l'impression que l'un d'entre eux
s'appelait mamadou koulibaly mais moi je
classe pas les jeunesses en fonction de
la race excuse moi j'ai dit qu'une
partie effectivement de la jeunesse
d'une certaine immigration est
effectivement est sur représentée dans
les actes de violence en les mêlant les
uns et dans les airs
c'est un fait
les secours que vous n'avez alors
rokhaya diallo alors moi je pense
effectivement qu'il faut pas avoir peur
de notre jeunesse mais qu'il faut plutôt
avoir peur pour elle je rejoins ce qu'a
dit nicolas l instant dans dans le sens
où on vit dans un contexte extrêmement
incertain
je trouve que c'est un petit peu
malhonnête de dire que il ya une
violence
aujourd'hui qui est particulière moi je
renvoie quand même aux années 80 où des
bandes de jeunes s'affrontaient les
années 80 c'était les années des
skinheads des années où effectivement
les gens se faisait tabasser en pleine
rue
quand on regarde les chiffres en fait on
se rend compte qu'en 2020 je pense que
si on le sait des réseaux sociaux et les
téléphones exactement ces cas une
scission visibilité en fait deux formes
de violence qui n'étaient pas visibles
au grand public
c'est parce que vous avez vous les avez
maintenant quatre ans portait exactement
savez-vous ça c'est donc à cette
visibilité qui est amplifié par les
réseaux sociaux par les chaînes info si
qui ont besoin de se nourrir sur
d'actualité de faits divers donc la
france entière aujourd'hui a accès à des
images auxquelles elles n'avaient pas
accès s'il avait twitter dans les années
80 on aurait été effrayés de grands
risques on est s'est tapé dessus en
plein paris quand on regarde les
chiffres en fait on voit qu'en 2020 dans
paris intra muros il ya 83 rixe et ce
qui change en fait par rapport à avancer
que la plupart des jeunes était inconnu
des services de police de police et que
les banques n'étaient pas identifiées
donc la nouveauté c'est qu'en fait des
jeunes qui ne sont pas structurés dans
des formes de violence organisée décide
de s'en emparer et moi ce qui m'inquiète
dans le sas est de voir qu'autant de
jeunes prête si peu d'importance à
l'aigre l'intégrité physique d'autres
jeunes c'est à dire que de voir que des
jeunes soient à ce point
insensible soit capable de tabasser des
gens qui leur ressemblent et de jeu
laissé pour mort ça ça m'inquiète je me
dis mais quel genre de personne est
capable à ce point de faire preuve de
sico et d'empathie
raquel garrido bon moi ça me fait
toujours un peu rire des d'entendre jean
messi a parlé de la france vous ce soir
vous allez dormir dans un salle un
quartier chic de paris 1 alors que moi
je voudrais vous devez vous donner des
leçons à tout le monde sur le fait que
vous connaissez mieux tout le monde mais
en fait non ce soir vous dormez dans le
7e arrondissement bilingue vous vous
dormez dragées non je manie en train de
saint denis les jeunes y compris maison
de sa famille oui bah oui bah c'est pas
les mêmes
moi je sens que tu as deux secondes
quand on est dans le c'est cela
justement on va pas la télé ou de
prendre de haut tous les chroniqueurs en
disant vous ne connaissez pas la france
et moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que évidemment il
les jeunes chez moi évidemment ce sont
mes voisins les enfants de mes amis et
les amis de mes enfants etc et et que au
fond vous vous êtes en train de monter
en épingle
un discours qui n'a qu'un seul objectif
c'est d'alimenter une sorte de frénésie
de frénésie en vue de la de la politique
politique en fait on va la trouver dans
un bel arrêt oui rien à fiche est en
train de me dire c'est qu'en fait c'est
le discours qui crée la réalité c'est à
dire qu'en fait nous on parle oui mais
que cette parole en fait elle n'a aucune
habilité à dire que ce qu'ici à ceux qui
agressent et si un quitus ce qui est
gratuit
si vous dites qu'ils font ça je vous ai
fini aux gens mais si je dois je le
vengerai problème pour dénoncer toute
violence je suis pas d'accord pour que
la voiture se met à bron ont été
caillassés je suis extrêmement préoccupé
comme tout le monde d'ailleurs par les
violences entre groupes de jeunes et je
trouve ça vraiment terrible je fais des
violons dans ma part tout justement d
avery des rangers messia parce que moi
quand il ya des ratonnades à lille
organisé par génération identitaire oui
ou non dans les bas et qui est à la une
est condamnable
tu peux pas soutenir une caméra celle
aurélien vous n'êtes pas plus renseignés
mais ce que je veux dire aux
manifestants pour btp tout à l'heure au
delà de ça je pense que le don le
véritable danger aujourd'hui c'est que
il y à toute une jeunesse qui en rupture
de la france compte quand il ya une loi
séparatistes quand on parle de
séparatistes en aurait 9 pc series biens
religieux non
non non il y à toute une partie de notre
jeunesse
oui dans l'ue27 et immigration fait par
les migrants musulmans qui est musulman
lié non non non qu'ils aient dit
musulman il ya bien sûr la loi séparatif
naquirent religieux joue un rôle
tu parles des principes et tuba dans une
banlieue et qu'on te dit wallah sur le
corps en salle c'est franc bay année
émergents mois on commence vraiment et
ce qui commande et en réaménageant sais
c'est que tu as des tas de personnes en
france des tas de jeunes en france qui
veulent pas vivre comme nous qu'ils
veulent pas s'habiller comme nous qui
ont ni viard les vidéos qu'ils veulent
pas à se saluer hommes et femmes que
comme nous et non qui leur reproche à
nous donner de sufi nation et bien c'est
ton art hâtive là c'est à celui qui te
permet mais j'en suis fier parce qu'il
ya un an tu es né ici avant d'été
pénalité de grâce à mon art est et
j'aimerais que tu remercies ton père et
ta mère
qu'a donc ses parents et parents de dire
quelque chose aux gens ce qui est très
inquiétant
merci pour le petit tacle homophobe mais
juste dire c'est épouvantable ma part en
part au de l'unita maman et ton papa
situation
ça fait un nom que tu te pavane pour
reprendre un mot qui a été dit pérore
sur les plateaux télé avec un narratif
c'est à dire tu es comme la petite thaïs
tu vas au bout de ta phrase en disant
c'est un truc sympa je vais aller au
bout depuis tout à l'heure je te regarde
droit dans les yeux je me défile pas je
te dis regarde moi bien parce que non
c'est moi je suis français je veux dire
quelque chose que tu le veuilles menti à
plusieurs reprises suis français bat
excuse moi a commenté relancer quand la
chose moins que le mot apparaître si tu
veux mon cas bon écoute moi et comme
disait pas si le maton de maths
écoute moi je vais dire quelque chose tu
rentres hâte de te tromper et que tu
passes à côté d'une partie des français
rocaille et moi nous sommes de la même
génération en moi la déception est que
le dira quel sens on a déjà eu lieu à
des discussions
la gauche nous a exterminé en terme
d'ambitions patriotique chez d'accord
examen interdit d'être patriote
ça c'était lionel juste jospin avec
black blanc beur moi j'ai pas besoin de
foot pour être français je suis français
toute l'année qui est zidane qui joue
pas mais ce que je veux que tu
comprennes c'est que si tu passes ton
année qui vient parce que là c'est top
chrono dans un an et une élection
présidentielle moi je le dit et on a
déjà parlé de ça il va y avoir des
responsables si des gens dont tu t'es
séparés comme le front national
arrive au pouvoir parce que ça sera un
échec collectif les banlieues c'est un
état d'esprit physique parce que c'est
une réussite jusqu'à aujourd'hui écoute
moi je te dis la vérité à temps mais
manifestation avec des blancs en plein
paris tais toi tu les qualifie m'a pas
fait c'est jamais dit si tu dois te
baptiser aussi
avec des blancs pour cent il y avait des
droits non à 32% règlement d'alice
doit-on avoir peur d'un autre âge